Водолази перевіряють, чи немає вибухівки навколо прикордонного катера та під ним.
Прикордонники ретельно узгоджують маршрут.
Після оголошення на Донбасі Операції об'єднаних сил замість АТО
заходи безпеки в акваторії Азовського моря суттєво посилили.
Це один з катерів Маріупольського загону морської охорони.
Щодня екіпаж з трьох прикордонників на чолі з 27-ми річним капітаном Володимиром Вдовенком
має виконувати одне і те саме завдання.
Недопущенняконтрабандиі проникнення у Маріуполь військових формувань
Така небезпека завжди існує з боку окупованого узбережжя.
Звідси до лінії розмежування приблизно 16 кілометрів.
І в2014-му та15-му роках українські прикордонні катери звідти обстрілювали -
загинули два прикордонники, втрачено два катери.
Наразі Держприкордонслужба України оцінює ситуацію в морі як складну.
І не лише через наближеність лінії фронту та анексію Криму.
Прикордонники мають справу ще і з наслідками двостороннього договору,
що був укладений між Києвом та Москвою ще в2003році.
Вже 15 років Азовськеморе має статус внутрішніх вод двох держав - України та Росії.
Тож тут можуть вільно пересуватися прикордонники обох країн.
Інакше кажучи, ані в українських, ані в російських прикордонників немає чіткої лінії на мапах,
яка була б обома сторонами визнана державним кордоном.
Тож, порушувати нема чого
і вільне пересування часто означає ось таке небезпечне наближення.
Цей інцидент між українським і російським прикордонними катерами стався13 вересня
цього року біля Довжанської коси.
Росіяни повідомили, що слідують згідно з завданням.
Після чого направилися в сторону нашої тактичної групи
та почали здійснювати небезпечні маневри.
Порекомендувалинабрати їм безпечну дистанцію,
на що вони відповіли знов небезпечним маневром.
Українські прикордонники назвали такі дії провокаційними і такими,
що порушують міжнародні правила судноплавства,
і стверджують, що це не поодинокі випадки.
Знімальна групаDeutscheWelleз об'єктивних причин не може здійснити таку саму зйомку
на катері російських прикордонників
і взяти коментар щодо причин та обставин подібних ситуацій.
Єдине, що можна констатувати, виходячи з офіційних та неофіційних даних,
це те, що прикордонники обох країн суттєво збільшили свою присутність
і на узбережжі,і в акваторії.
З українського боку ми бачимо нові прикордонні катери.
Цей, виробництва України, 2016-го року випуску - з сучасної системою навігації.
А це - більш потужний, катер спецпризначення - "Онікс".
Є ще і дещо оновлений прикордонний корабель "Донбас".
Українці, як і росіяни, про реальну кількість військових кораблів
та їх озброєння не повідомляють.
Але з обох боків контроль за переміщенням цивільних суден - посилений.
Перевіряють геть усіх.
"Нептун" на зв'язку.
Підкажіть, будь ласка, ваша ціль і кількість екіпажу.
Політична ситуація навколо Азовського моря все більш напружена,
особливо зараз, коли Київ запускає процедуру розірвання Договору про дружбу з РФ.
Президент України анонсував навіть створення координаційного центру
щодо протидії російській агресії в Азовському морі.
Розглядаються і варіанти залучення міжнародних спостерігачів.
Зброю до сьогодні жодна зі сторін не застосовувала.
Екіпаж катеру Маріупольського загону морської охорони сподівається,
що до цього взагалі не дійде.
Адже це означатиме не лише виникнення нового відкритого конфлікту вже на морі,
а і потенційну небезпеку для Маріуполя, який у червні2014-ого вже був під контролем сепаратистів.